Fox & Friends invited dr. foul Chi on TV
and Brian Kilmeade to try to explain
medicine to dr. foul Chi and it really
didn't go well now we have a number of
different Fox News sort of related clips
today we already did Fox News trying to
rewrite history pretending they were
always taking the virus seriously and
what has happened on fox news over the
last eight weeks regarding coverage of
the virus has been borderline criminal
I'm not saying it is criminal but Fox
News is being sued and they likely will
be sued more times for their spreading
of disinformation about the virus later
we'll get to more about that but for now
here's what happened I have a clip for
you from Fox & Friends where they
invited on dr. Anthony Fauci dr. Anthony
Fauci of course the top infectious
disease doctor in the country and Brian
Kilmeade tried to explain to him how
medicine works and it didn't go well so
let's get right into the clip what
they're talking about when we pick it up
is a survey it's not a clinical study a
survey of doctors around the world and
in the survey doctors were asked what
are you giving people for coronavirus
treatment and it's really important to
understand that it is a survey and they
also asked what have you seen be
effective when you've given it to people
we are linking to the survey I will talk
about the survey momentarily but let's
take a look at the clip listen to Brian
Kilmeade 'he's confident ignorant
arrogance trying to explain medications
to doctor foul Qi and then pay special
attention to the silence at the end of
the clip which shows that foul Chi
realizes there's not actually a factual
assertion to address while brian
kilmeade is just sitting there waiting
expectant
75% of all everyone in Spain is taking
with success French and Chinese take it
and then doctors are taking it there's a
lot of positive things and I would love
be very curious doctor to see if anyone
who's taken this for lupus or arthritis
has gotten cuz of the coronavirus that
would be one way to go the other way to
see about this study but let me talk
about some way to get to get I do you
want to respond to that no I mean
obviously this is a good drug in many
respects for some of the diseases you
mentioned and the one thing we don't
want to happen is that individuals who
really need a drug with a proven
indication don't have it available but
just one guy can't escape getting back
to you said seventy five percent of
doctors think that it what we really
don't care what seventy-five let me
think it works you know that's not the
issue no no I should clarify because I
said Spain seventy two percent of the
doctors in Spain are prescribing it okay
good okay well that's fine we almost
need a new term called Fox splaining
pouchy has to be commended for being
endlessly patient with completely
clueless people so this study as claimed
by Brian Kilmeade is the source of a ton
of disinformation it's a survey which
asked doctors indicate which medications
if any you have personally prescribed or
have seen used in your setting to fight
kovat nineteen and indeed 61% of doctors
in spain have prescribed or seen
chloroquine prescribed then the survey
asks and again it's just an it's an
observational survey based on the memory
of doctors of the medications you've
personally prescribed or seen used
please indicate which ones are most
effective and again globally you have
37% saying we think chloroquine is the
most effective but also remember that
chloroquine is one of the most used the
numbers are not adjusted for that thirty
two percent say zithromax antibiotics
thirty two percent say nothing has been
effective and then you've got other
stuff so think through the data
37% on a survey say chloroquine seems to
be the most effective
32% say antibiotics it just so happens
chloroquine is also one of the most used
and antibiotics have been some of the
most used that does not suggest to me
that we have proper data or anything
approximating a randomized clinical
trial 32% altogether say nothing has
been the most effective so even if this
wasn't a survey like imagine that
instead of just being a survey of what
do doctors remember imagine that this
was some kind of properly controlled
test these numbers still don't actually
tell us that much about chloroquine so
we've got to be really really careful
about this stuff now I hope chloroquine
works
I hope anything works I have no idea
logical attachment to chloroquine with
or without as if throw Meissen Trump has
been touting it so Fox is touting it you
need real doctors to test this stuff
this is how you end up in these fact
free worlds where the opinion of Brian
Kilmeade
in the minds of many fox viewers is
worth just as much as the opinion of dr.
Anthony Fauci who by the way now needs
armed security because of the threats
from Trumpets who believe that Anthony
Fauci is either some kind of anti Trump
plant or even worse
some kind of deep state operative that's
the United States 2020 that we are now
living in so we all want something to
work but we need to detach ourselves
from the political nonsense when we
explore what might work
that's called science we have dozens of
existing medications that are being
tested there are new medications in
process combinations of those drugs a
huge portion of Trumpets are now
emotionally attached to chloroquine if
it works great and I hope it does
remember if it works we've been talking
about it for weeks now but long before
Donald Trump was if it does work
remember it will have nothing to do with
Trump if it doesn't work it will have
nothing to do with Trump we need doctors
and scientists telling us what works
not brian kilmeade and a confused and
sleepy Donald Trump during press
briefings I'm really excited that one of
our sponsors today is helix sleep I
sleep on a helix mattress at home I
absolutely love it and that's why I
reached out to them about sponsoring the
David Pakman show buying a mattress in
the past was always a huge guessing game
for me I didn't know what I actually
needed I didn't know what I would like
but helix has a sleep quiz on their
website you tell them your body type
your sleeping position your back pain
issues you might have and their tool
matched me with a mattress that is
perfect for me
it's cool enough at night it's the right
firmness I generally just do way better
sleeping these days because of the
mattress helix was awarded number one
best overall mattress for the last two
years by both GQ and Wired magazine it
is well deserved I can tell you
firsthand every helix mattress comes
with a 10 year warranty you can try the
mattress risk-free for 100 nights and
they will even come pick it up at your
house if you don't love it but I know
you will all of my viewers will get up
to two hundred dollars off your order
and you'll get two super premium pillows
for free when you go to the link right
underneath this video